back after the break um
so we have two more talks uh for the
afternoon session if you're in
california otherwise it's a
a in a different type of session in
other parts of the world
and they're going to be a sort of a one
on the intersection of blockchains and
law
and other one with economics
and first stock will be given by
primavera so
please go ahead the virtual stage is
yours and thank you for giving your talk
thank you um so this is um
this is more of like a ligand and
government stalk
and um so the talk is about like what is
the interplay uh the interconnection
between
um uh regulation and governance and
between
the rule of law and uh the rule of um
of good and um and so yeah my research
is mostly about trying to understand
like uh the extent to which
uh blockchain technology can be used uh
but as a regulatory technology so
as a way of incorporating some
technological guarantees
um in order to achieve some regulatory
compliance but at the same time like
what are the tools that we can lever
leverage in order to
um also ensure the proper governance of
this technology
um so just to um
i mean the short overview uh basically
like
those characteristics of blockchain
technology that um
distinguishes itself from a traditional
software platform so
decentralization um the global and
transnational nature
of the network the resiliency
uh the unknown correction which is
particularly important
in in this uh for the purpose of
historic
uh in the sense that as opposed to
traditional software platforms
where the platform operator can
impose and just by unilaterally modify
the code and the infrastructure of the
platform and that
modification will automatically be
imposed and therefore adopted by all the
users of the platform
uh in the case of a blockchain-based
network every change in the protocol
actually have to be
accepted so there is no possible
correction
um and then of course tamper resistancy
this transparency in order to enable for
the verification then reproducibility
and
um at least in the context of permission
as blockchain limits anonymity
and then finally um in the context of
blockchains that
enable the creation of smart contract
and the guarantee of execution
and so those characteristics are what
leads um to qualify
uh blockchain-based network as being
like on one hand
costless in the sense that uh
we don't no longer need to trust
centralized operators
um and instead of being based on a
trusted system then it becomes more of a
proof system
um and therefore it becomes possible to
disintermediate
and on the other hand which is connected
to the disinformation aspect is the
autonomy
that is inaudible systems meaning that
on the one hand we can automate
operation but at the same time
um those operations become instead of
unstoppable in the sense that
no one can unilaterally uh change modify
or even stop the executions of
from the software and so this raises
some
interesting questions at least
concerning this um
uh the complementarity of the
discrepancy between
uh the rule of code uh which is
incorporated within a blockchain
resistance and the rule of law which is
uh defined by the regulatory system and
so
as a as a short overview
about the rule of law so the principle
is essentially that
no one stands above the law
that uh everyone is equal under the law
and the law should apply equally to
everyone
uh those should have to be transparent
clear precise
and accessible uh to everyone and then
everyone should have
uh timely access to um
legal remedy and just this mechanism and
this of course comes with the
necessity of having an independent
judiciary in order to ensure
that that the political power does not
actually
uh control the judiciary process
and this stands in contrast with the
rule by law where the idea is that
some actors or the sovereigns um
stand above the law and therefore they
can actually
proceed through the instrumentalization
of law as a tool of political power
and so if we look at the internet
at least in the early days then there
was this general
belief at least or narrative that
the internet is neither uh governed by
the rule of law and is also not
governed by the real bilo but it is this
kind of
independent space that come that cannot
be regulated because
government do not have the the capacity
or at least the height uh to exhaust the
sovereignty of
this decentralized network uh but then
of course uh as time passed and uh
as we see the the emergence of the
centralized platforms
which somehow um
process a lot of the traffic on the
internet then
um we can see how
slowly this decentralization therefore
the narrative that came with the
decentralization to no longer apply
and so when we when we look at the
internet today at least like
in the in the current state of affairs
with like those large online operators
uh we can say that the the internet is
currently regulated by the real
buy code um meaning that
those online operators can actually
instrumentalize
the code of the platform the
architecture as a tool of
political power and to serve their own
economic or commercial interests
and so we speak about uh digital
federalism and functional sovereignty
but basically the idea is that
those platforms are uh above
uh above the above the code above the
the law that is generated by the code
and they can unilaterally
change it at any time and so and this
can be
to some extent contrasted um with a
blockchain based infrastructure which
can be said to be real
governed by the rule of code um because
again
in that case no one is above the code um
so because of like the the
polycentricity and the disintermediation
and decentralization inherent in those
systems
no one can unilaterally modify uh
the rules of the game uh and so there is
this kind of
technical sovereignty and even the
people that designed and deployed
applications on the blockchain do not
actually have the power
to change those rules um and so if we go
back to
uh the previous theorization of like
code's law you know introduced by
lawrence lessig
in the early days um we can see that
there is actually a distinction between
two different type of code is law uh we
have the more traditional lex
informatica
which is essentially the real buy code
and then we have the likes cryptographic
which is the
the blockchain based system which is
governed by the rule of code
and that is important when we think
about regulation because
it is actually quite easy to regulate
the
a system that is ruled by code because
then it's it's if is to identify who is
the sovereign
who is the actual online operator that
control this code and then regulate
those online operators in order to
indirectly regulate the individuals
uh whereas in the model of like
cryptographic because we have lost
those traditional centralized operators
then it is harder
to to regulate the system unless we can
find
uh some new intermediaries that
that could themselves be regulated um
and so this this leads us back to this
uh
again like the initial narrative of the
internet where lauren slasic introduced
the notion of irregular ability
uh to to to present the difficulty that
exists in regulating such a
decentralized and transnational network
and in the blockchain space uh people
like to refer
to the system as being illegal meaning
that
they exist outside they create their own
technological framework that exists
outside
of um of the regulatory framework and
therefore cannot be
touched or affected by the law
and we can see already quite a few
applications where we can see this
discrepancy of like this conflict
between
uh the use of blockchain technology and
the existing regulatory frameworks
whether
it's about money laundering whether it's
about like uh deployment of um
the centralized marketplaces for the
sale of illegal
goods or services whether it's about
incorporating directly into the
blockchain some illicit content
which could be like copyright
infringement which could be like
institution to violence or
links to pedophilia etc uh and then
of course i also like the question with
the how to be forgotten whether
a blockchain based system can actually
be compliant with those rules
um and then one field in which this
discrepancy between
the rule of code and the rule of law
is quite apparent is the context of
poverty
rights where traditional property rights
are defined by the law and therefore
they can also be taken away by the law
um and so if i illegitimately acquire a
particular piece of property then a
judge can declare that i'm not the
legitimate owner of this
asset and therefore can seize it from me
who has when we move into the model of
blockchain-based assets and
cryptographic property then those
property are hardly defined by the code
and therefore they can only be taken
away but
could so if i legitimately
if i legitimately acquire some bitcoins
then
regardless of what a judge might say
then no one
can actually seize them from me unless
they could specifically provide for that
uh and then similarly in the context of
contracts um
there is this interesting discrepancy in
the sense that traditional legal
contracts are defined by the law
by contract law and that they need to be
enforced by a third party
by the judiciary which will look at what
is the actual
intention of the parties in order to
decide how to enforce the contract
whereas in the case of a smart contract
they are defined by the code and they
are automatically enforced by the
underlying technology
and so the enforcement is not done by
looking at what is the intention
of the party but only what is the actual
wording
of the code and so um we have had
a very interesting example of this
discrepancy with um
with the uh incident of the dao hack um
where god is the centralized investment
fund and they managed to raise um
about like 150 million dollars and then
at some point um the avenue t was found
in the code and
was used in order to um move
about 50 million worth of it away from
these
smart contract and so this created a
very heated debate and discussion within
the interim community
about um what is the
actual um what is the actual thing that
we should look at shall we look at what
is the intention of the parties that
have entered into this smart contract
and of course those parties did not
intend uh to enter into
a contract in which it was possible to
take the money away
or rather we should actually just look
at the specific wording of the code in
which
this this action was legitimate because
it was actually
um incorporated within the call of the
smart contract and so
the question was shall we intervene in
order to take the money back
uh and give it back to the original
holders
um and if if we need to look at the
intention of the code then
the the attacker that exploited this
flow
actually had stolen the money and so it
was actually legitimate to restore the
balance
whereas if we consider the wording of
the code then
that the attacker actually did something
legitimate and then
taking the money away from the attacker
then we'll qualify as a theft
um but then of course the the question
is kind of a mood question because
regardless like even if this question
had been taken to a judge then
regardless of what the judge would have
said uh because there is no centralized
authority that can enforce the law
then um the trustless
character and the autonomous character
of the dao is such that it's really
difficult to actually
enforce this decision um into the system
so what happened is that um
the community somehow had to come to our
to a solution on its own um and because
of the non-coercivity
of the system then um
it has led to a bifurcation of fog uh
between the it's one one one network
that actually decided to
modify the protocol in order to retrieve
the funds
and one that refused to retrieve the
protocol which has become interim
classic
so the interesting thing if we actually
compare it back to the rule of law
um is that this actually can be regarded
as a state of exception
in which um there has been a decision
uh to depart from the protocol rules and
so in the same way as the rule of law
can sometimes be displaced
by in the case of an emergency within a
state of exception
then the rule of code as well can
actually be displaced
um when there is a similar state of
exception but then the question is
who is the sovereign uh so in the in the
in the traditional rule of law system
then there is always a sovereign that
takes the power
but in the case of a blockchain it's
it's not clear
who that sovereign actually is um
and uh and this is because of course
there are like all those different power
dynamics that come into play
and um the the even the decision of
actually entering into a state of
exception
is something that needs to be done
through this critical consensus
um and this is interesting because it
actually showed the
importance of uh governments and social
norms
we see in the regulation and within the
operation
of um of a blockchain based system and
we can
we can see how different blockchain
network might actually favor
different values and social norms and so
we can see for instance like in the
context of
bitcoin which actually has a very strong
um
flavor towards imitability and
universability and like this notion of
code it is law and the protocol should
never be
modified in particular to to to change
things retractively as opposed to
in that case at least like the ethereum
community which on that particular
incident has decided that
as long as there is community consensus
that something
can actually be modified uh then it is
okay it is it is still
compliant with the with the principle
and the values of the blockchain
community
um so what is interesting is that while
on the traditional like informatica
traditional internet platforms
then as the law start having struggled
to
regulate uh directly uh internet user
but can actually
regulate the infrastructure the
architecture that in order to then
regulate users in the case of um
in the case of abduction-based system
it's actually social norms it's actually
the governments that can
affect the architecture of the system
and therefore indirectly
affect the operation and the and the
behavior of its users
um so of course this is required
to distinguish between the governance by
the infrastructure
which is like what has been specifically
and explicitly codified within the
blockchain-based infrastructure which is
oftentimes formalized and but that is
only about the enforcement
like is about the real that are codified
and automatically enforced by the
technology as opposed to governance of
the infrastructure
uh which is oftentimes much less formal
and and i'm
quite quite invisible uh but that's
actually the important one because
that's the one that can
that elaborates the real that will then
be codified within the infrastructure
but this is also
the governance of the infrastructure
that can actually declare a state of
exception
and that can affect and modify those
rules in specific circumstances
and so who who are those uh
uh who are those actors that can
actually play a hole into the
government's
of the infrastructure and buy the
infrastructure so we have of course at
the
the layer zero we have like the
developers so the
people that are proposing the possible
changes to to
to a protocol and then we have like the
network participants so the miners and
the validators that
need to accept those changes by
upgrading their clients
but then we also have um other types of
actors
which somehow have a very strong
influence into
the decision making of which changes to
adopt and
which forks to follow and those are like
all the
all the influencers which are oftentimes
people that have like
uh the founder of project or the people
that have very good
uh technical knowledge the people that
are
like very vocal on social media and so
forth
and then we have like a for the mining
pool which aggregate like um
a lot of demanding power but then also
the supernodes which are
uh for instance the like
the blockchain explorer the
cryptocurrency exchanges
which somehow act as an aggregator
between
many users that rely on their services
and so eventually technically they don't
actually have
that much power from uh from an economic
and from like um from um
from a political perspective they
actually have a lot of power because
if they choose to follow one fork rather
than the other then
all the users that are on that uh
exchange will
obviously follow the same the same
network as in [ __ ] and then everyone
that wants to interact with those user
will also follow this
the same fox so they do actually have a
very very strong
um power into into influencing uh the
shelling point
um and then um
so there is of course the the question
of like uh
those uh within like the blockchain
governance rules uh so all those actors
play
together uh within this polycentric
system in order to
uh come to a decision which needs to be
consensual
and then but there are like different
types of rule that can influence those
uh this government's procedure and
some of them are endangering us which
are uh designed and imposed by the
community itself some of them
are exogenous meaning that they they
take them from the outside
um and so in the case of endogenous
words so we have of course like the
onshore government schools which are
encoded directly into the blockchain
protocol or within the code of
smart contract but we also have like all
those rules that the community
has implemented um in order to
uh facilitate governance of things that
cannot be codified directly into the
blockchain and so that's like the
improvement proposal uh procedure it's
like the
the the community social norm and so far
but then in terms of exogenous world we
also need to account for like
um specific fields that are technical
rules that are
um imposed potentially by actors like
whether that's like the
uh internet service providers whether
that's like the
mining device manufacturer or something
which
which can codify specific drills that
come from the outside and yet are
affecting
the operation of a blockchain based
network but then we also have those
uh those external rules that are
uh that are not directly part of the
of the community but yet are affecting
the community member
and that can be like either between like
contractual agreements
between the different actors but also
the various flaws and regulations that
might affect
the way in which a particular community
will make a decision um
and this is interesting to look at
especially given like those um
those different decisions that have been
taken on the one hand from the dao
attack
in which the eternal community has
decided at least
in in in a large majority to change a
protocol
in order to fix a problem that was
considered
uh to to be um
to be worth of intervention uh whereas
the party bug which actually was um so
like
money got frozen into a smart contract
and
um um in that case eventually
the fix was actually quite simple like
it was very clear
how to resolve the problem and it was
much less controversial because
it was not really about taking money
away from someone it was actually just
about
reviving a particular smart contract
um somehow the decision was not to
intervene
and the question then was like uh what
why
um why has there been like a different
uh decision and again it relates to the
state of exception
and in the case of the doubt that really
was an emergency
there was a particular limited amount of
time in which a decision could be taken
in order for those funds to be
retrievable whereas in the parity case
uh there was as much time as necessary
to make this decision
and also it was the dao attack was like
the first
the first of a kind it was the first
time that this situation came about
and so it was an exceptional situation
the parity back as the second case um
to some extent if if
if a decision was made to intervene then
it could not just be
uh justified as an exception but it
should have been justified as a process
and that means that it will require
setting up a procedure justifying and
explaining and formalizing
when is it that intervention can be done
who are the people in charge of deciding
when these interventions should be done
and of course these also come with
potential responsibilities on the people
deciding and so all of sudan
this suffering will emerge um
and so in the case almost not about the
parity bar then we also have seen
uh some people that were actually
involved in the decision making of like
the um
the italian improvement proposement that
actually decided to
uh step back from their position by fear
of legal liability
uh because they thought that if they
were to take a decision and that
decision could then be
hold against them uh from the from the
from the legal system um and so the
conclusion is like
um we we we cannot
really uh assume that blockchain like
this will this whole
vision of blockchain as an illegal and
unregulable system
is uh is flowed and it's uh eventual
maybe direct regulation is much more
difficult than in a traditional online
platform there is still homes for
intervention um
and then the question of course is like
what kind of intervention what kind of
actors can
we can what what kind of pressure can we
put on those
new actors that are that are affecting
the governance of blockchain technology
so
there are discussions about whether the
developers or the maintainers should
actually
uh hold some kind of fiduciary duties
and therefore be responsible for the
uh uses that are made of the software uh
there is discussion whether well maybe
we should just criminalize the user and
implementing some kind of legal
liability for
transacting with a particular blockchain
network with
a particular application on those
network but of course that's very
difficult because
most of those networks are anyhow upset
animals and transnational and so forth
um there is also those new
intermediaries that
could also be pressured by government to
comply with specific regulatory
constraints
perhaps preventing some online
cryptocurrency exchanges to actually
transact with specific addresses which
have been held to
be doing illicit work are potentially
like
requiring mining pools to in your ignore
certain transactions that
that government doesn't want to have but
um
the problem then is really that there is
no way it is possible to actually
exhaust pressure on on any of those
actors and
different governments can actually uh
use their power to
to to exert this pressure the problem is
that because of the polycentricity of
the system as a whole
um it's not enough to it's not enough to
regulate one actors
that it's actually necessary to regulate
all those actors and uh
so they from from a regulatory
perspective
like governments if they really want to
have their uh
as an influence on the system they need
to understand
like the whole um the whole
complexity and the whole dynamics and
power dynamics that exist but between
the technical layers of like miners and
minus and um and validators but also
everything that happens at the mark of
chain and social
layer of developers of influencer and
commercial operators because they are
also the ones that are
actually dictating what the selling
point will be
um so yeah i think that that's about it
for the presentation
um so yeah
i'm happy like basically the condition
is just like regulation of blockchain
technology
um requires a very
deep understanding and assessment of
what is the governance of each one of
those blockchain-based network and
the the regulation needs to go via
a government's approach as opposed to
the traditional top-down
regulatory approach that can be done on
traditional online platforms
thank you very much yeah well i actually
do have a question so
you mentioned as examples of i guess
difficulties in trying to um
um i guess govern a blockchain
in the the the the dow hack and also the
party bug
uh now there was some some time ago
right in the meantime you know a number
of projects made it as
their one of their let's say uh
distinguishing
points you know some type of maybe more
refined self-govern
self-governance do you have any i don't
know
projects or academic studies that you
would highlight as
you know in some interesting direction
for baking self-governance
into some ledger itself or or or you
haven't seen anything that
uh seems like sufficiently interesting
to you right
um i mean i'm actually it's it means my
own
but i'm starting uh from january i'm
starting a five-year
long european project on on this
specific question which
is um data is actually a lot of focus
on um governance of blockchain
technology from
a technical layer uh so basically
you know whether it's like you know
business-like like engineering
government but it is still like using
um technology in order to govern
blockchain technology
but there is actually very little um
analysis and like uh in-depth you know i
think it's it's almost like an
ethnographic
uh study that is required to actually
look at
all the actors that are operating
and influencing um each other outside
of the of the like on the social layer
um so i mean academia is starting slowly
to
to to look at uh the question of
option governance but i think what is
lacking is really like
um and in that analysis and ethnographic
and research on
what is the actual afghan governance of
those communities
that is oftentimes not documented then
oftentimes the community themselves
don't
really are not fully aware of because
it's like a lot of things that happen in
the um
in the background and in the backstage
um
so yeah like uh i'm i'm actually
starting this
this program this this project to expect
specifically to do that so this is uh
some
research grant from the from european
union on the study of
interaction of on-chain and off-chain
governance yeah
it's like a european research council
grant
and yeah the idea is to to
understand better uh all that is
happening in the social layer of
blockchain governance
in order to then try and create uh
governance structures for blockchain
community that properly integrates
the on-chain layer and the off-chain
layer together
okay so and so i agree with that there's
probably a lot that needs to be said
in this area but you know in terms of
you have a did you sort of
had a look at the current landscape of
like examples
where you would start studying start
studying uh as examples whether they
were good or bad
examples uh empirically in the past few
years or
um like i mean until maybe maybe three
years ago maybe tesla's was made perhaps
the the most
prominent sort of governance right
but you know since then it's not been
the only one uh
you can argue like you know how
successful it was but uh
uh do you have any any thoughts about uh
existing projects or ideas out there
that uh
um yeah so the idea is like to look at
uh
the like the three main which is
blockchain ethereum and theseus as like
his studies
and then to identify some pilots
some pilot project which are much
smaller um
and yet they are experimenting uh it's
actually new
new governance practices um
mostly at the like not necessarily the
production level but at least at the dow
level so
whether it's like dao stark um
aragon and um like
various smaller projects
whose objective is to actually uh design
dials which have a form of option
governance integrated within them
uh and then experiment on the small
small project and have this kind of like
participatory action research
so that we as we analyze and as we tell
rise
about uh unchain and option governments
we can also
try to model uh specific um
like to elaborate specific models and
then test them directly on those
communities and see
how it works essentially because um
we don't have a theory of uh distributed
governance that can be
practically instantiated into a
blockchain community and so
uh it's kind of like this lean process
of
looking at how things works trying to
listen to like
what are the pain points and things like
that and then
collectively trying to you know by
integrating
academics that have been working on the
question of governance in like
many different fields but none that none
don't necessarily have like
in-depth blockchain knowledge but that
have very very good knowledge in like
the more traditional
question of um of governance and
integrating those with
the actual blockchain community
themselves and trying to find like uh
how um insights
from the more traditional uh academic
world can actually
help this community evolve in terms of
governance and this versa is like
how how can the new tools that are
provided by blockchain technology
um actually inform also provide new
insights
that can be fed back into the governance
of more traditional
uh institutions like how how can how can
you incorporate
this technology in order to increase for
instance like the confidence and the
and the trust in in in other types of
institutions
people have other questions
yeah well actually i do have one more
question so this year sea grant
what institutions does it touch and you
know what uh what
which researchers are uh is it like a
large grant
with like many people or is it like a
smaller uh team smaller
uh so it's between uh the siena rights
in france and the european university
institute in florence
and it's like a two million euro grant
for five years and so i think it's uh
it's gonna happen
the idea is to is to create a little
team and uh like maybe like
three phd and uh three to four postdoc
students um that will do this research
and then
trying to find um as many contributors
and collaborators
um around and and like the goal is
really to
to connect with um so to actually hire
only people that are non-engineers uh
that are like
social scientists lawyers and so forth
within the actual because that's like
the analysis of this social layer
um and then connect uh with as many
um engineers and computer scientists
to actually um validate those insights
and to collect
collaboratively work out those different
elaborate those models
uh but the idea is it comes from the
observation that there is um
a lot of uh research projects that are
actually focusing on the technical layer
there is actually not not many so far to
date at least on the social layer
and the only way that you can actually
understand is socially is of course by
also understanding the technical layer
so the idea is really like let's create
a team of like
political scientists and sociologists
and lawyers together
that work that analyze the social layer
and then uh
integrate within the within the within
the work and within the group
um other disciplines that can also
contribute validate brainstorm together
[Music]
to further the insights
other questions before we take a break
um
yeah okay so uh with that mindset uh
thank you
for the talk uh according to schedules
we're just right on time which is
wonderful
uh according to this schedule we'll take
a 20 minute break and resume at
a 1 pm california
so see you all soon